in the early decades of the 20th century
the discovery of something called
antimatter raised a significant problem
this new substance called into question
how our matter filled universe could
exist at all let me explain in 1928 Paul
Dirac came up with a new and elegant
equation to describe how particles like
electrons behaved when they travel close
to the speed of light
surprisingly Dirac found that his
equation always had two solutions sort
of how the square root of a positive
number always has two answers direct
recognize that one solution described
the electron but the other well that was
a mystery which he first dismissed as a
mathematical artifact he later said it
took him three tortured years to summon
the courage to claim that this other set
of solutions was describing something
real antimatter that is the first
solution described an electron while the
second described an anti-electron the
anti electron would have the same mass
and spin as the electron but it would
have an opposite electric charge now
since the electron has a negative charge
the anti electron would have a positive
charge which is why we also call it a
positron Dirac's equation says the same
thing is true for all particles quarks
have anti quarks and just as quarks can
make of protons anti quarks to make up
anti protons and antiprotons and
anti-electron x' they can make anti
atoms and so on
Dirac's theory was a remarkable
achievement
if proved incorrect it would double the
number of known particles in the world
just four years later in 1932 Carl
Anderson took this picture of a particle
racing through a bubble chamber his
measurements showed that it had the same
mass as an
electron but a positive electric charge
the first detection of antimatter
verifying directs mathematical
prediction now we come to the puzzle
when matter and antimatter come together
they annihilate and this raises a big
question why is there any matter left
after all if matter and antimatter are
identical except for having opposite
electric charge and since as far as we
can tell the laws of physics don't have
a preference for a plus sign over a
minus sign we would expect equal amounts
of matter and antimatter to be created
at the Big Bang
and then as they intermingled the matter
and antimatter would all annihilate
leaving a sea of structureless radiation
but if this were the case the universe
as we know it wouldn't exist so what's
going on physicists have been puzzling
about this for more than half a century
some have wondered whether the
antimatter got separated from matter and
might still be out there existing as
anti planets anti stars anti galaxies
maybe even anti universes others have
imagined that just after the Big Bang a
tiny imbalance between matter and
antimatter somehow crept in indeed to
avoid total annihilation scientists have
calculated that for every billion anti
protons there must have been a billion
plus one protons that's a tiny imbalance
but it would have left over just enough
matter to make all we see in the
universe today to figure out which if
any of these theories might be right
scientists are undertaking a range of
experiments to understand antimatter
with far greater precision and all this
is part of a grand quest to answer a
question that
as simple as it is profound given that
matter and antimatter annihilate how is
it that we exist
you
[Music]